[Music]
it's time now for CBS morning's deals
where we share some items that might
help make your day a little bit better
all at exclusive discounts to Star
shopping now scan the QR code on your
screen go ahead and do it visit
cbsdeals.com as well lifestyle host Gail
bass is in the house
we have something that can help your
hand relax after a long day of stress
maybe playing some ball or golf oh yes
absolutely if you have poor circulation
you've been typing a lot you're sitting
at your desk this is the dextra
cordless Okay Hand massager with
compression is that warm yes it is warm
it is warm it has heat vibration
compression let's just up that a little
bit so it gives you a little squeeze
how's that what's going on I know that's
like a yeah it's massaging my head yes
absolutely it has a wide receiver I've
had some aches and pains with these
hands yeah hair stylists we got you
there you go you want to put that on
Giselle says she could I feel that yeah
go ahead Gail in that as well okay
Andrew this one here we go then turn
that one out the next thing you have has
to do about barbecuing yeah and somebody
said before we went on here Gail that is
not real food please don't eat it that
is it what is the price we have this for
55 off it's 89 at cbsdeals.com the best
deal you're going to get online on this
right now
these guys the best deals for summer
we're going to have them all summer and
our first one here is the grill time so
after you're finished playing with that
no this is good Gail this is good after
finish playing with that you want to we
want to snack on these because when my
hand never gets tired picking up a
burger though
who's does kale everyone's sorry picking
Nobody Does
this the grill time is fantastic because
it is portable it's lightweight even
when it's cooking you can pick this up
and it has real charcoal flavor you
could take this lid off like that see
how much food you could put out another
wow you could serve up you could make
five servings for five adults or one
teenager depending on what you got in
the house and there you go you put this
lid on so you could check what's being
smoked or cooked inside this heats up in
four minutes it has real charcoal inside
so it would get the charcoal it gives
you that that chocolate taste that you
want and only just about 10 of the
charcoal that you that you normally
would use and it heats up in four
minutes can you use that in your kitchen
you can use this in your kitchen but you
could also use this when you go camping
you could take this to the park this is
a summer must-have and if you have a
small apartment you can put this on the
patio if you don't want to commit to a
big giant Grill and what I love is our
price that we have we have this for 40
off
119.99 at CBS also known as 120. from
the background no no under 112. the
tailgate as well right this is the
tailgater baby that is 105 days and
football starts what do we have here the
charge Hub I love these because it's a
charger yes absolutely yes always need
to have a job
[Music]
these are these are some of our best
sellers because the everybody needs them
if you have a house full of kids or it's
just you and you have multiple devices
you could charge your tablet your phone
and look you could do your remote so are
we looking at this one this round this
one right here this one some of them
have three some of them have four we
even have up to five and some of them
have wireless charging you put it right
there
charging right there is that your
boyfriend that is that is
a close-up of that come on so any way he
is not for sale
okay Gail being all nosy is that your
boyfriend he wanted to take you hiking
I'm gonna go now
[Applause]
I'm just kidding to the beach all right
I'm here eight men who are involved this
is just this is perfect for the beach
and so much more check this out yes I
use this in the back of my car you could
see you could use it for shopping but
this is the ultimate beach bag it's
build a bag if you go to the beach it's
full of sand these there you go that's
the back of my car I did it for grocery
shopping but at the beach you put this
down it doesn't tip over it's made of
but you're building your liking yeah you
want yeah you can you could do it to
your like and we have multiple colors
It's Made of This durable Eva so it's
the color will pick the color you picked
the he's already at he's already on
summer vacation
and you know what you could even use
this for ice you can on your back patio
throw some ice in it too you can work
drinks cool what's the price on that uh
the price on this we have it for 109 100
under a hundred dollars
thirty percent off you will never need
another beach bag after that Tony all
right let's go
here we go we're not going anywhere
thank you we appreciate you of course we
partnered with all of our companies to
get these deals to buy anything that you
saw or other products and the QR code on
your screen right now or head over to
cbsdeals.com to start shopping now we
will be right back